f on retrouve notre correspondant du
liver craag bonjour à vous gulliver quel
est le programme du secrétaire général
de l'onu lors de ce déplacement dans la
capitale ukrainienne
alors surtout il va visiter les
banlieues de kiev putsch à posto mail ir
pin's et en courant de la matinée qu'il
va se rendre dans ces villes satellites
au nord ouest de la capitale il va
notamment se rendre sur le site d'info
ces communes abuja bout de chats ou les
assassinats par balles pour une grande
partie d'entre eux deux civils a fait
que certaines personnes ont appelé les
crimes de la russie en ukraine pour le
moins des crimes de guerre sinon des
éléments d'un génocide il y a plus de
400 civils qui ont été tuées à bout de
chats seul encore plus si on prend toute
la région de kiev hier le maire de bruch
à disait que les forces russes opérait
avec des listes visiblement il avait des
personnes précisent qu'ils avaient des
instructions de tuer pour une part en
tout cas des gens qui sont morts
seraient fonctionné comme cela ce qui
suggère qu ils tuaient exprès des gens
qu'ils considéraient comme des
activistes ou des personnes pouvaient
être d'une manière ou d'une autre utile
à l'ukraine et à l'effort de défendre
l'ukraine ce qui n'exclut pas selon la
définition de génocide en droit
international que cela puisse être
qualifié de génocide mais ce n'était pas
le cas peut-être selon ce que disait en
tout cas le maire de boutiers hier qu'il
tue est juste complètement au hasard
tout citoyen qui bougeait dans la ville
bonjour gulliver comment voler la
situation sur les différents fronts
alors il n'y a pas énormément de progrès
pour les russes dans le front du donbass
sauf à côté de la ville d'izu qui
contrôle et ils semblent avancer vers le
sud vers le sud ouest et vers l'ouest
disent yum ceux qui sont les analystes
suggèrent qu'ils essayent de contourner
les forces ukrainienne pour ensuite
foncé vers le sud et essayer d'attaquer
les villes ukrainiennes dans le dos de
basse de ce clavier comme atos que
mézières soir les ukrainiens disait
avoir repoussé une offensive un peu plus
au sud logiquement les russes tournerait
à gauche si vous voulez essayer d'aller
vers le sud est là les ukrainiens ont
pour le moment en tout cas repoussé une
attaque en ce sens mais ils disent que
les russes continuent à pilonner tout le
don de basse tout la ligne de front dans
le donbass de leur artillerie et aussi
qu'ils auraient emmené des ombres fort à
zoom même au nombre de saints sont
blindés merci glee va vous allez suivre
version pour nous à la visite d'antonio
guterres s on va vous retrouver tout au
long de la journée